sandy alcatraz coming off that tough
loss
against the saint louis cardinals but he
finished that outing as the leader in
major league baseball and innings
pitched
simeon on one two a swing and a miss and
sandy striking with a good changeup good
way to start the night
it is four days in a row with the same
starting lineup yeah that's right
and uh one pitch one out beau buchette
retired
chop to third birdie from foul territory
long
throw got him at first what a play
by john bertie in a great stretch on the
other end by aguilar
ross stripling on the mound for the blue
jays frost couldn't have pitched any
better than he did his last timeout
against the new york yankees
he hits a three hopper out to marcus
simeon at its second and an easy play on
the first for out number one
and here's his counterpart the center
fielder for the marlins starling martay
trying to bunt for a base hit backhanded
by stripping third base side of the
mound and a nice play on defers
for out number two
stripling gets aguilar swinging on a
high fastball
and he has a nice three up three down
inning
offense not the problem sandy alcantara
might be the problem today that's his
second strikeout
both strikeouts tonight coming on the
changeup a good one
again
as biggio draws a four-pitch walk
2-2 from sandy slow roller to short
mickey goes the short way and cindy's
got two innings in the books
how about this 94 mile an hour fastball
by stripling
who the last five starts now plus
tonight is getting
so much swing and miss on his fastball
two outs nobody on last to the second
scoreless game here at lone depot park
here's a zeus
sanchez
puts a charge into this one dead center
field that's a home run
everywhere wow 439
feet to straight away center field
well that's a home run in 30 ball parks
including low depot
so two no doubters now with two strikes
if you want to get getting out
swinging a miss stripling gets him up in
the zone to end the inning but the
marlins take a one-to-nothing lead
ground ball up the middle and miggy is
there to retire maguire for the first
out
a little bit of slider right there gets
the strikeout his third marlins have
a one-nothing lead
as birdie pops it up guerrero
backpedaling
and it makes the catch 3-2
and he got him swinging on a fast ball
away three up three down
go the marlins one nothing they lead the
blue chase to the end of three
with that delivery it's so smooth that
almost rocks you to sleep
oscar gets a hold on and lines it up the
alley in left center field the first hit
of the night for the blue jays is a
two-out double here in the fourth
out to left sanchez started in now
drifts back and makes the play
sandy threw four and because of sanchez
good change up down and in to get martay
there'll be no two to aguilar and that's
lace to left for a base head
drops in front of the left-hander guriel
so azu zaghilar
has the second marlins in the game you
can see that left index finger off the
bat
runner goes and a swing and a fly ball
to left field
duriel's got room and he makes the catch
to retire the side
one-nothing marlins lead the blue jays
at the end of four
i think they might have to play some
small ball against this guy because he
doesn't give up much
reese maguire hits one off the end of
the bat into left field for a base hit
and maguire who had a four for five
three double game on sunday has a hit
tonight with two down in the fifth
the point being you know through this
lineup we saw the change up the slider
in the sinker all working early
and he's been getting nothing but great
results including that little tapper
stripling retired five good innings
swing and a miss and a ball up and in
six strikeouts now
for stripling and the 2-2 pitch
a high fastball lifted to right field
but not that deep
coming in now to oscar hernandez to make
the catch and it's a three-up three-down
inning
for ross stripling now bechet who was
grounded out on the
first pitch of each advan and he got hit
a 98 mile an hour fastball i believe got
him on the left arm
and the first pitch with beshette
running and the pitch is low and bechet
will steal
second how about that here's vlady and
now he's going to deal with guerrero 3-0
and you know vladdy's got the green
light
and he slashes it into right field for a
base hit
and just like that the blue jays have
tied the game here in the sixth
it is such a tough middle of the lineup
for the blue jays
fastball on the outside corner to get
alcontra strikeout
number seven for ross stripling
2-2 grounded to short here comes bashed
fires it on to first and guerrero will
make the play on the other end as the
marlins leave a man on
and it's on to the seventh in a
one-on-one time
a breaking ball now a change up no more
fastballs for you if you're going to
bang it into center field for a base hit
and now some discussion as to whether
this little shot up the third baseline
is that a foul ball it starts foul
it is foul but it was back on the line
when alfaro
picked it up
backhanded by aguilar the flip to sandy
and he
is through seven again nothing in two on
sanchez who homered in the second
and hits one hard up the middle
backhanded by
biggio and bobbled by guerrero
bluejay's had the shift on and that's
why biggio the third baseman was back
behind the second base bag and made a
nice play on it
you don't see it often and for the
front-running mvp candidate
that may be the lowest point of the
first half sometimes catching the ball
as easy as it seems
not so easy
2-2 and a swing and a miss to get them
and end the unit
a very nice sitting for tyler chatwood
very efficient tonight he's got the
change up working
great fastball he's been riding it in on
the hands of those righties
tonight like he did right there but
guerrero finds a hole between third and
short and he is aboard with his second
hit of the night
sandy deals on a hop to jazz has a play
over to first
and once again sandy alcatra through
eight
crisp innings of work
swing and a miss by leone mesa makes
quick work of him
striking him out on three pitches two
down
one two and he got him boy what an
inning by
tim meza three up and three down
going to the ninth tied at one
it's it's fun to watch gavin do it
and look at this now he gets one he can
handle hits it into the right field
corner
and he's on his way to second with a
one-out double he laid off that tough
pitch
so now you're looking for a fastball and
you're thinking
extra base hit so now a big spot for
lurtis guriel jr o for three
shift on and he swings and hits it hard
to left field and this ball is down
it'll get to the fence biggio will come
in to score
goriel into second with an rbi double
and the blue jays
have the lead here in the ninth it's out
there right now with a one run lead
bottom of the ninth inning is jordan
romano
marty running pitch taken for a strike
throw down
and they got him at second reese maguire
throws out starling martay
and a swing and a miss at 99 to get him
for out number two
theo one fastball jammed him popped up
maguire looking for it back of the plate
and he's got it
and the blue jays will win it
outstanding work
by the pitching staff tonight and the
blue jays take the ball game by a score
of two to one